new polling shows President Trump
trailing four of the Democratic
presidential contenders former Vice
President Joe Biden leads mr. Trump by
nine points senators Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris are
also ahead Biden is set to unveil a new
health care proposal in Iowa today ed
O'Keefe is in Des Moines and what's his
plan well Anthony who's trying to set
himself apart from some of his
Democratic opponents pushing so-called
Medicare for all plans by instead
unveiling a plan that bolsters Obamacare
and biden is set to say that he'll take
on any one republican or democrat that
seeks to try to replace the current
Affordable Care Act Biden's plan would
cost about 750 billion dollars over the
next decade and would provide a public
option if needed
it would allow Americans to import
cheaper drugs from overseas and the plan
would be paid for in part by ending the
Trump tax cuts health care is a hot
topic on the campaign trail in recent
days in this weekend another Kennedy
South Bend Indiana mayor Pete Buddha
judge told us he believes in universal
health care the way I've talked about
doing it is a Medicare for all who want
its solution in other words we take a
version of Medicare we make it available
on the exchanges is a kind of public
option now if the corporate world can
come up with something better than
they've done so far great maybe they can
find some way to compete but I'm not
banking on it 20 of the Democratic
candidates are set to be here in Iowa
this week for events focused primarily
on health care and preserving Social
Security Anthony yeah meanwhile at Bay
Toa Rourke revealed yesterday he
recently learned he and his wife are
descendants of slave owners what exactly
did he say he said that they basically
had found out recently that they had
this in their past and that an issue
that he talks about frequently in the
abstract is now far more personal he
also says that he supports paying
reparations to the descendants of slaves
O'Rourke is the second prominent white
politician in recent days to find out
that he's a descendant of slave owners
last week it was Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell in that interview with
Budaj edge the mayor told us that he
thinks it's time for white Americans to
speak far more frankly about race saying
that it's time to fix racial and
Justices in our lifetime Anthony thanks